>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Edward Widmer: Secretary Chao,
Mr. Hastings, Senator McConnell,
members of Congress, Ms. Compton,
distinguished guests, good evening.
Specifically, aloha to students
and faculty of University
of Hawaii watching the livestream at
the William Richardson School of Law
at the University of
Hawaii at Manoa,
and the Imiloa Astronomy Center at
the University of Hawaii at Hilo.
Also, a special greeting to Peace
Corp volunteers at viewing parties
in Belize, Guatemala,
Jamaica, Tonga, and Fiji
and to other volunteers
around the world.
I'm Ted Widmer, director
of the Kluge Center.
On behalf of the Library of
Congress, it's my pleasure
to welcome you this evening
as we continue a wonderful
five-year collaboration
with the Daniel K. Inouye Institute
to commemorate the life, legacy,
and values of the late
senator Daniel Inouye.
Before we begin, please take a
moment to silence your cell phones.
Also, please note this event is
being live-streamed and recorded
for the Library's website.
And if you have a question
this evening,
you are giving the library
permission to use your question
for a future broadcast
as in forever.
So please ask your question clearly,
and please ask only one question.
And for those of you who
are tweeting this event,
we are using the hashtag
Inouye and hashtag Kluge.
Senator Daniel K. Inouye was an
Olympian figure here in Washington
and in his home state of Hawaii.
Born in Honolulu on September 7,
1924, to Japanese American parents,
he graduated from high school less
than six months after Pearl Harbor.
After the ban was lifted on Japanese
Americans serving their country,
he enlisted in the Army and served
in the famous 442nd regiment
of the U.S. Army, a unit of Japanese
American soldiers who fought
with extraordinary gallantry
in Italy, France, and Germany.
On October 21, 1945, in the
war's final weeks in Europe,
he was severely wounded
in battle after taking
out two German machine gun
nests and lost his right arm.
He returned home with a
distinguished service cross,
bronze star medal,
two Purple Hearts,
and 12 other medals and citations.
He received extensive medical
treatment, and his commitment
to bipartisanship may have stemmed
from the lifelong friendship he
formed with another wounded veteran
in the same hospital, the future
Senator Bob Dole of Kansas.
After coming home, he graduated
from the University of Hawaii,
then law school, and became Hawaii's
first representative in 1959
when Hawaii became a state.
Three years later he
was elected senator,
part of a freshman class inspired by
the young President John F. Kennedy,
including his brother,
Edward Kennedy [inaudible]
and George McGovern.
He served for nearly half a century
in the Senate, leaving a rich legacy
that includes the National Museum
of the Native American just
down the street and
prominent service
on the Senate Watergate committee,
the Senate Iran Contra Committee,
and the Senate Appropriations
Committee,
which he chaired from 2009 to 2012.
He was awarded the Congressional
Medal of Honor on June 1, 2000,
for his military service,
a day I was proud to be
in the audience at the White House.
After his death on
December 17, 2012,
he was posthumously awarded the
Presidential Medal of Freedom,
becoming the first senator
to receive both the Medal
of Freedom and the Medal of Honor.
Tonight the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress
and the Daniel K. Inouye
Institute present the third
in a five-year distinguished
lecture series
to commemorate Daniel Inouye's
commitment to bipartisanship,
moral courage, public
service and civic engagement.
We also celebrate tonight another
great American who believed
in courage and civic engagement,
President John F. Kennedy
born 100 years ago this month.
This year's lecture was
planned in collaboration
with the Kennedy Center
and the Peace Corp to focus
on values held dear
by both President Kennedy
and Senator Inouye.
It was also designed to honor
the special role of Hawaii
in the development
of the Peace Corp.
As the panels outside indicate, more
than 7500 volunteers were trained
in Hawaii between 1962 and 1972.
This evening our speakers
will consider the topic
of inspiring a sense of
service and idealism.
They will highlight the
evolution of the Peace Corp,
which was established by
President Kennedy on March 1, 1961,
and discussed how it's ideals
remained relevant today,
five decades later.
The event is made possible
by a generous donation
from the Daniel K. Inouye Institute.
We are most privileged to have with
us this evening the Senator's widow,
the driving force behind his
legacy, Mrs. Irene Inouye.
I ask you please to join
me in recognizing her.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I'd now like to introduce
our distinguished panelists,
as you will hear the Peace
Corp played a significant role
in both of their lives.
Reed Hastings grew up locally.
His father was an attorney for the
Department of Health, Education,
and Welfare under President Nixon.
One of his early memories,
according to an interview he gave
in the New York Times, is
getting a tour of Camp David
from the then Attorney
General, Elliott Richardson,
and noticing that Camp David
had Golden toilet seats.
There were no such amenities
in Peace Corp, where he served
from 1983 to 1985 after
attending Bowdoin College.
He taught math in a high
school in Northwest Swaziland
where there was no
electricity at all.
But it could be said
that Netflix began there.
He took his GRE exam in Swaziland.
He was then admitted to Stanford's
program in computer science.
He enjoyed a very successful
business career.
He created and sold
a software company,
always displaying the versatility
and self-reliance prized
by the Peace Corp. That
background prepared him well
for the day he received a
late fee from a video store
after renting the moving Apollo 13.
He was in fact six week's late
and owed $40 in on-the-spot.
He decided to create a new
company for people who wanted
to rent movies for
longer than one day.
Netflix was founded in 1997
as a DVD subscription service.
Ten years later in 2007, it started
streaming content via the Internet.
It now has over 100 million
members in over 190 countries,
more than the population of
Germany, France, or England.
Reed is an active educational
philanthropist.
He served on the California
State Board
of Education from 2000 to 2004.
He is on the board
of many educational organizations
including the California Charter
Schools Association, Dreambox
Learning, the KIPP Foundation,
Pahara and the Hispanic
Foundation of Silicon Valley.
He is also a board member of
Facebook and was on the board
of Microsoft from 2007 to 2012.
Our other panelist,
Secretary Elaine Chao,
is the 18th U.S. Secretary
of Transportation.
At the age of eight, she
immigrated from Taiwan
to the United States,
speaking no English.
She graduated from high school
in New York, Mount Holyoke
and Harvard Business School then
began a remarkable public career
that has always given
inspiration to others.
From 2001 to 2009, she was the
24th U.S. Secretary of Labor,
the first Asian American
woman to be appointed
to the Cabinet of American History.
Prior to that, she was the President
and CEO of United Way of America,
and before that the Deputy
Secretary of Transportation.
And she was the director of the
Peace Corp from 1991 to 1993,
an eventful period in World history
and especially for the countries
in the former Soviet Union.
She was nominated for that post
by President George H. W. Bush,
and during her tenure
she developed one
of President Kennedy's original
ideas for the Peace Corp,
which is that it should operate
in the Eastern European countries
where development and
expression were often stifled.
Under her leadership, the Peace
Corp expanded into Poland,
Latvia, Lithuania, and Estonia.
Our conversation tonight will
be moderated by Ann Compton,
former ABC News White
House correspondent.
She joined ABC News in 1973.
She has covered seven presidents.
On September 11, 2001, she was the
only broadcast reporter allowed
to remain on Air Force One
during the dramatic hours
when President Bush was unable
to return here to Washington.
She's traveled around the
globe, through all 50 states,
with presidents, vice
presidents, and first ladies.
We're delighted she can
be here with us tonight.
After their conversation, we will
a lot some time for questions,
but first we will begin the Q and A
with some video recorded questions
from Peace Corp volunteers and
University of Hawaii students.
Then we will have microphones
available,
and we will take a few
questions from the live audience.
Please join me in welcoming
our distinguished panelists
to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Have a seat.
[ Background Noise ]
>> Ann Compton: Thank you.
Good evening.
Aloha. During the questioning
tonight, and the conversation
between these two guests, we're
looking for that thread that goes
between public service
and the idea that the rest
of our collective experiences lead
into that and can illuminate that.
Elaine Chao, I've known you since we
were both young girls covering the
Reagan administration.
She actually brought
her spouse tonight,
Senate majority leader,
Mitch McConnell, here.
They got married much after
Elaine and I first [inaudible].
Thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
Secretary Chao, you
began as a banker.
>> Elaine Chao: Yes.
>> Ann Compton: And your first
government job was a White
House fellow.
How did you get from there
into a Cabinet position,
and what was that thread that
got you to head the Peace Corp?
>> Elaine Chao: The
thread is curiosity.
As you've heard, I'm an
immigrant to this country.
I didn't understand
so much about America.
So when I was a banker, I thought--
I was involved in a
number of transactions.
If it was with a private sector, it
would just be four people, myself,
the banker, the borrower, his,
and most of the time it was a he,
his lawyer, my lawyer,
and we would be able
to finish a deal in two hours.
But whenever I did a government
deal, there would be reams
of documents, 35 lawyers on
their side, the government side,
and it took like months
to close a deal.
So I was kind of curious.
Why did this happen?
Why the difference, and so I heard
about the White House
fellowship program, and I applied.
But it was out of a sense
of love for this country,
curiosity about how our
government functioned,
and wanting to understand the
larger society here in American.
>> Ann Compton: And then you had
been in a deputy Cabinet position,
how did the Peace Corp rise out of
that, and I remember what happened
in 1991, the year that you
took over the Peace Corp
because I remember missing Christmas
with our four little children.
It was the day the
Soviet Union fell about
and President George Herbert
Walker Bush flew from Camp David
to the White House on Christmas
night to address the nation
and congratulate Gorbachev
for having the courage
to break up the Soviet Union.
You now have a Peace Corp. There
were no Peace Corp representatives
on the ground in those
country, were there?
>> Elaine Chao: Yes.
You know, President George H.W.
Bush was actually quite prescient,
and he had a very good
feel for world affairs.
So in the summer of 1991, he already
had a feeling that the collapse,
I think, because we've never
talked about it in this sense,
and I'll explain, but
he must have had a sense
that the former Soviet
Union was going to collapse,
and that the peoples in the
former Soviet Union will need help
from a people-to-people
kind of exchange,
but they'll require
different skill sets.
They will require a more
sophisticated kind of assistance,
and so I was in California
in June of 1991,
and he mentioned his interest
in placing me at Peace Corp,
and he said the Peoples
of the Soviet Union,
if this ever came about, would
need assistance in adjusting
to a more industrialized,
and to join the community,
the international community, if
anything like that were to happen.
And I have to give my husband some
credit-- he wasn't my husband then.
I was just going out with him.
But he was cute.
He still is.
So I discussed it with him,
and he was very encouraging
of my entering the Peace
Corp as a director.
>> Ann Compton: Reed Hastings,
so you graduate from Bowdoin,
you're going to go into the
Marine Corp, how did that turn
into the Peace Corp and then
into an entrepreneurial,
legendary entrepreneurial career?
>> Reed Hastings: Well I wanted
to do some form of service,
and the Marine Corp has a
program where you can do summers
at Quantico, and then when you
graduate you get commissioned
as a second lieutenant, so I did
the junior year, I guess summer.
And it was hard.
I realized, you know, the
system is very well organized
and very impressive, but,
you know, as a junior person,
it's following orders
a lot, and I realized
that might not be my sweet spot.
And so I was able to petition out
of that and then join the Peace Corp
where you're sent to many distant
places, and you really have
to make it up as you go along,
and it really develops your
leadership muscle in that way.
>> Ann Compton: Did you get
to pick where you were going?
>> Reed Hastings: No.
I got assigned Swaziland.
This was all pre-Internet,
and so, you know,
you go to your local library,
and you look up an encyclopedia.
I never heard of the place, but
like, you know, many of the places
in the world that Peace Corp
volunteers are sent, you know,
it's a very optimistic people, and
I was a high school math teacher
and just had a fantastic experience.
>> Ann Compton: Well, let
me switch to this, Reed,
you live in California,
Silicon Valley.
Many of the students watching
in Hawaii from two locations,
the Washington Beltway seems like
a strange creature and probably not
at times a very appealing one.
Do you think from your
point of view,
can you explain how
you view Washington
and whether a public service career
at this moment probably doesn't look
that appetizing to
some young people?
>> Reed Hastings: I think it
looks appetizing to many people,
and whether it's Washington or
Sacramento for us in California,
you know, some people choose a life,
like the secretary that's dedicated
to public service decade
after decade,
and I think that's very powerful
because you develop a lot of skills
and connections, and you
could be more effective.
Other people like myself
dabble in it.
So two years in the Peace Corp.
Then I'm in the private sector.
Then I volunteered on the state
board of education in California,
so I spent a lot of
time in Sacramento.
>> Ann Compton: You became chairman.
>> Reed Hastings: That's right,
but you're basically supporting the
professionals, like the secretary,
that are dedicating their
lives, and so as long
as you realize different people make
different choices and that's okay
and you work together,
I think there's a lot
of different opportunities to
either do I would call it, you know,
small tier occasional service
like I've done and mostly focus
on the private sector, or long-term
in many different roles,
like the secretary.
>> Elaine Chao: I totally
agree with that.
>> Ann Compton: Good.
>> Elaine Chao: And I think
it's really important actually
to have these different
paths into public service
at federal, state, local levels.
I think our nation benefits
when people have a diversity
of experience in the private
sector, in the volunteer sector,
and they come into
the public sector.
All of that is helpful.
>> Ann Compton: And from the
point of view of the students
who are watching tonight from
Hawaii, should they worry
about being put off if they
see Washington looking chaotic
right now?
>> Elaine Chao: Democracy
is chaotic.
Democracy is messy.
So it's really funny.
I teach English to some
immigrants from Asia,
and they keep on asking me, they
keep on say, who's in charge?
And I tell them, there's
nobody in charge.
But then they say, you and I
know each other now well enough,
you can really tell me,
who's in charge in America.
So the dynamic aspects of our
society and the balance of power
between the different branches at
the federal level, I mean, you know,
making laws is like making
sausage, it is messy.
Democracy is messy.
We have such a cacophonous
nation of people.
People talk about partisanship,
gridlock, and our country is made
up of, our Congress is made up
of representatives, senators,
and congressmen, who
represent where they're from,
and they're giving
voice to their people,
the people that they represent.
>> Ann Compton: And
who sent them there?
>> Elaine Chao: Who sent them there?
So we have such a diverse country
so of course our national discourse
and our dialogue is going to be
kind of chaotic and messy as well.
But that's democracy.
>> Ann Compton: So let me ask
both of you, how do you express
that to the people, the young
Peace Corp volunteers are
out there dealing with it.
Reed do you have stories
about when you [inaudible],
about ways in which people's lives
were changed because you were there
and Secretary Chao for you as
well, ways in which you know
that during your tenure lives
were changed in places overseas.
>> Reed Hastings: Yeah, absolutely.
You know, the Peace Corp
and many things similar
to it are great experiences to
just grow a sense of the world.
It's inevitable that if you grow up
in the U.S. and don't get a chance
to travel, as most of us don't,
that, you know, you have one view
of the world, and once you've
lived outside the U.S. for a while
and you just see how broad it is
and the wonderful nature of people
around the world, it's a
very powerful experience.
And so I just felt, you know, very
connected to everyone, and again,
you know, times may look
chaotic today, but, you know,
they're not really that
chaotic compared to World War II
or the civil year war or the 13
years before we had a constitution,
you know, the first 13
years that are public.
So, you know, you have to have some
perspective, and you might also look
at it and say in difficult times is
when service is most
needed and most valuable.
So I certainly would encourage
any young person to be involved
and not think about, you
know, the last 20 years as,
you know, a turnoff of politics.
>> Ann Compton: Were there
times with some of the students
and residents that you dealt
with that you felt you really,
you were able to make the connection
to help them better
understand America.
The 1980s were a different
time, but not that different.
>> Reed Hastings: Yeah, but
I think you really do it
as a Peace Corp volunteer
by example.
It's not, you know, giving lectures
on the separation of
powers or something.
You know, it's living
your life in a rural area
and being a decent person
and, you know, for them,
it breaks down the
theory of what America is
to make it very real and personal.
And so the Peace Corp has always
been about a very person touch,
and with the secretary's leadership
around the world, you know,
I'm sure you get to visit, I got
one little slice of Swaziland.
>> Elaine Chao: I did, I did.
>> Reed Hastings: And you probably
have a much broader view of it.
>> Elaine Chao: But Reed was so
inspiring when he said what he said
about the chaos, and I think
the Civil War, 13 years before,
and I didn't think about
that, but that's really true.
So when you ask about what's
really, what differences I've seen,
you know, when I was director
of the Peace Corp and I went
to visit all these Peace Corp
volunteers, and when I would speak
with the Peace Corp volunteers, and
there are some who are watching now,
they tell me, and I feel
of myself that I change
because I went to visit them.
And there are some volunteers
here from Tonga, I went to Tonga,
and I was single at the time, so
they gave me the wedding dress.
You know, it's like a straw mat
that you wrap around yourself,
and it was the wedding dress.
And I'm sure the volunteers
in Tonga understand this.
And which were the other areas,
America Samoa did I hear?
I was there.
You know, the hospitality of the
local people is just overwhelming.
Every single place I went,
the tremendous outpouring
of warmth toward Americans is just
so, so impressive and inspiring.
>> Ann Compton: And
that personal one on one
with residents may
have a softening effect
if politically a country
is not as warm
with the United States'
relationship as--
did you ever have any instances
where you worried or thought
of bring Americans
home from a country?
>> Elaine Chao: We did.
As the Peace Corp director,
the first responsibility is
to ensure the safety and
security of the volunteers.
So we indeed did withdraw
Peace Corp volunteers
from I believe it was
Pakistan at the time.
We had a little problem there, but
when I was Peace Corp director,
one of the first things we
did, which I was very proud of,
was to have an emergency plan.
It was kind of sad
that we had to do this,
but because Peace Corp
volunteers are spread so far,
it took about three days of even
more to gather them together.
And so the world was changing.
>> Ann Compton: Were you
able to air lift them out?
>> Elaine Chao: Oh my gosh, yes.
And so we actually had
instituted a plan which enable us,
the local Peace Corp
office, to communicate
with Peace Corp volunteers faster
so that they can be congregated
in one place for immediate
evacuation if necessary.
>> Ann Compton: One question that
we heard from students who sent
in their questions and from
some in the Peace Corp as well,
asking whether the Peace Corp
volunteers representing the United
States around the world are
representing of the diversity
of the United States,
of women, minorities,
was that an issue at all for you?
>> Elaine Chao: Absolutely.
And I don't want to hog this,
because Reed is so interesting,
but yes, absolutely, I think Peace
Corp has a hard time recruiting.
I don't know now, but 20 years ago
when I was there we had difficulty
recruiting among communities,
people from communities of color.
I'm Asian American.
You know, my responsibility
is to my family.
I wanted to make sure that I
was financially responsible,
and the thought of taking two years
off and not getting paid except
for a very small stipend was just
not an option for a lot of people
in different communities.
And so I don't think
we should be surprised.
I mean that's just kind of like the
differences the cultural diversity
that we have, but we also have
to do a more affirmative job,
a better job, of making
known, you know,
what it's like to be a
Peace Corp volunteer.
>> Ann Compton: Reed,
in your experience,
especially when you
come out, you were both,
you are in the private sector
now, are there good arguments
for young people to get involved
who might not be traditional
Peace Corp candidates?
>> Reed Hastings: Yeah, I mean
I think it's a great experience
for someone who's pretty
independent minded,
and one of the great things the
United States government does is
delay any student loan
repayments during
that time you're a
Peace Corp volunteer.
>> Ann Compton: Now explain that.
I didn't realize that.
That might be a big factor.
>> Reed Hastings: Yeah, so, I mean
many of our students who have built
up debt during [inaudible]
college, and then if you go
in the Peace Corp, that is
deferred for that time period.
And then the Peace Corp is
doing a better job of reentry
and skills development and things.
So it's a remarkable program because
it's now, you know, about 50 years,
and if you think of most programs
created in I don't know the last 20
or 30 years, they get
pretty partisan.
They get associated
with a political party,
and the Peace Corp has really
been a very bipartisan effort
that has wide support, and, you
know, that's quite unique really
in the last hundred years.
>> Ann Compton: Let me broaden
from that to a bigger aspect here.
Both of you have worked,
you have worked
and you are currently
in the private sector.
What are the lessons that you
from the private sector learn
that are skills that you could take,
that your Peace Corp volunteers
during your tenure could use
and that skills that you took
or think now you took with you.
Let me start with you, Mr. Hastings,
what the private sector skills
that really can be employed
when you're overseas
in a position representing
the United States like that.
>> Reed Hastings: Well I
would say a bracing failure,
because when you're 22 and 23 and
you're on your own in a remote part
of the world, you do a lot of
stupid stuff, and, you know,
some of it works out, you
know, but, you know, someone,
I look at the misadventures, like
this bee-keeping project I started
to do for local entrepreneurs, it
didn't work out, but this other one,
which was water tanks in local high
school did, and so you just got
to be willing, got to be relatively
fearless and just try things.
And I think that mindset of being,
you know, okay with some failure
and being willing to try
is tremendously helpful
in the private sector.
>> Elaine Chao: You know,
as a former secretary
of labor, workforce--
>> Ann Compton: For
eight years, right?
>> Elaine Chao: Yes.
>> Ann Compton: All eight years.
>> Elaine Chao: All eight years.
The workforce of the future is very,
you know, is very interesting to me
and very important to the country.
I think what's really
important now as we go
into the future is the
workers of the future have
to be knowledge workers, and Reed
is in the area of technology.
Technology is changing so much the
way we live and work and travel,
because now I'm in transportation,
but what's really important is
the rod to work that was so valued
in the past is no longer valuable.
What's most valuable is creativity,
ingenuity, and the ability to think.
So the Peace Corp volunteer
experience is actually very helpful.
It doesn't really matter
if you want to, you know,
some people may say
well I've never worked
in the private sector
before, how can this help.
Every employer is looking for
workers who have the ability
to be curious, to learn, to adjust,
be flexible, and to be creative
and resourceful, and
these are skills
that if one can gain are very
helpful in any kind of job
in all three sectors, public,
private, and also the nonprofit.
>> Ann Compton: Well, and
that, of course the purpose
of this program is to
encourage young people
to consider public service.
Those are the kind of skills, the
creativity, the thinking to be able
to write, to be able to imagine,
which would be incredibly important
for a public service job as well.
>> Reed Hastings: That's
absolutely right.
I mean just pushing yourself to
do things that are challenge.
You know, whether it's banking and
whether it's Peace Corp, you know,
I think people learn the most when
they're in challenge situations,
and that's what stimulates
the most learning,
back to the secretary's observation,
it's continuous learning
in our society today.
>> Ann Compton: We had a
question about public partner,
private public partnerships
in a time
when government funds are
limited, when Americans want,
some American's want government
to have a smaller role,
at least want the private
sector to pick up some of that.
Where are those public-private
partnerships important
for this government now,
for the country right now,
and for the next generation
of leaders coming along?
>> Elaine Chao: Well, in terms of,
this is a very timely question,
because this administration
has as one
of its top priorities
the infrastructure,
the deteriorating infrastructure
of our country and how we need
to rebuild, refurbish, rehabilitate,
repair the existing infrastructure.
We do not have enough money as a
country to be able to address all
of the needs of the infrastructure
through government funding alone,
and we would not want to fund
direct government funding
on all these different projects
because they would have
deleterious impact on our deficit
and also potentially dislocate the
private sector markets as well.
There is plenty.
There is a lot of private
sector monies,
resources that are available,
and currently there are states
and other places, municipalities,
that prohibit the private sector
from investing in public
infrastructure,
so there must be a way in
which we cannot discriminate
against a private sector and
allow them to participate
in the rebuilding of
our infrastructure.
>> Ann Compton: An example,
a toll road, a bridge,
what are some [inaudible].
>> Elaine Chao: When you have
public private partnerships,
it's an effort by-- so for example,
in the infrastructure project,
the federal funding will
probably be about 200 billion,
and we will leverage that, because
a lot of times, just like C capital,
if you can get some
government monies,
the government monies is kind of
like a good housekeeping seal.
>> Ann Compton: Seal of approval.
>> Elaine Chao: And it will attract
and entice other resources
to come in.
So if of the 200 billion
there will be an opportunity
to attract private sector
funding through innovative ways
in which you can incentivize
the private sector to come in.
So, for example, just today, I
just came from Atlanta, Georgia,
to participate in the
opening of I-25.
It is the major artery in Atlanta,
Georgia, the bridge on this I-25,
on March 30th, erupted in a huge
fire that resulted in the collapse
of the section of the bridge.
This is a major artery in
Atlanta, and it messed up traffic,
but it's not a public-private
partnership
but through incentivizing
the private sector.
This project came in under
budget, ahead of schedule,
and in basically seven weeks it
was able to rebuild this section
of the bridge, and now Georgians
are able to be on the move again.
>> Ann Compton: Silicon
Valley, anxious to help
on public private partnerships,
and of course your involvement
in education in the state
of California is legendary.
>> Reed Hastings: You know,
some of the most exciting stuff
in private partnerships is things
like the private rocket
ship efforts,
which you never would
have thought ten years ago
that several different private
companies would be developing
rockets and doing amazing
things at amazing efficiency,
and then we have self-driving cars
and, you know, over the next five
or ten years, that's going to be a
tremendous revolution in, you know,
how we all get around and
people's relationship with cars.
So all these different sectors
are in the education side.
People are doing web-based learning
and augment what's happening
in a classroom to provide more
individualized instruction.
And so we're seeing
the role of technology
in multiple different sectors
where, you know, maybe a long time
about is mostly from the government.
>> Ann Compton: I want to ask both
of you, before we go to questions
from the audience, a
little bit about leadership
because there are students in Hawaii
tonight, and there are students
in the audience here and those who
will be able to see this online,
and they're always looking
for some kind of key
of what makes great leadership.
And I wonder if I could ask each of
you, starting with you secretary,
Chao, to talk about with risk of
oversimplifying things, leadership,
there are leadership qualities
that apply both to government
and to the private sector that these
students probably ought to focus on.
Well, I would turn the
question a little bit different.
I would say that leadership
can be learned.
When I was younger, I always
thought, you know, leaders are born.
Leadership can be learned.
So I think it's really
important for young people
to practice being a leader, and they
can do so in a very low-risk way
by volunteering with a agency
or with a cause they
feel strongly about,
and they can learn communication
skills, and they can learn all
about leadership skills as well.
Having said that, I think
a great quality for leaders
to have is a sense of integrity,
that they have to be true
to themselves, that they are
true to those that they serve,
and that there is a
pureness of heart.
>> Ann Compton: That's
a challenge though,
sometimes when your own personal
integrity is up against a brick wall
of something that seems
to be testing that.
Hold true to it?
>> Elaine Chao: I hope not.
I don't know.
There are very few times when most
of us are put in that situation,
I am very glad to say, but
when that situation does come,
I think it's really
important to know who you are,
what you stand for, your own values,
and be strong enough
to stand up for them.
>> Reed Hastings: Again,
maybe a little too influenced
by Frank Underwood because she knows
that House of Cards is coming back
in three weeks just to see
the fictional dark underside.
>> Ann Compton: House of Cards.
Oh, you may have started
Netflix and online streaming
and all those red envelops
that used to come in--
>> Reed Hastings: Yes.
>> Ann Compton: But
he's also the godfather
of President Francis
Underwood on House of Cards.
[laughter]
>> Reed Hastings: [Inaudible] I
would say, back to your question
on leadership, it's about being
the best person you can be,
and you could think of it as there's
two types of people in the world.
There's the people who pick up
the trash when they see it lying
on the floor and there's
the people who walk by.
And if you want to be a leader, you
have to be the first type of person.
>> Ann Compton: That's
a great answer.
One more quick question before we
start with those that have come in.
The idea of success in life
is obviously everything
that students want to aspire
for, all of us want to aspire to,
but can you learn from setbacks.
>> Elaine Chao: Absolutely.
>> Ann Compton: Secretary--
>> Elaine Chao: Those are the
best learning experiences.
I agree with Reed.
>> Reed Hastings: They're
the hardest.
>> Elaine Chao: Or the
hardest, but you learn the most.
Don't you agree?
>> Reed Hastings: Right.
>> Elaine Chao: You said before
that you have to be ready to fail,
and I think the hardest periods
in your life are the times
that you will experience the
greatest personal growth.
And so I think for those, everyone,
you know, for those who are thinking
about this all of us
encounter difficulties in life,
and we have to have the
strength to be able to prevail
and have confidence in ourselves,
but also know that this is the time
when we are really being
tested and being made,
our character and who we are.
>> Ann Compton: It's hard though.
>> Elaine Chao: It's very hard.
And of course if I didn't have
to do it, I wouldn't do it.
But those times, don't
you think that those times
when you have the most difficulties,
that's when I've learned the most.
>> Ann Compton: Reed Hastings,
I think probably 95 percent
of people have never
heard of Quickster,
but your company had what
some called a death spiral,
and look at you now.
Was that a key learning
experience for you?
>> Reed Hastings: Yeah,
that was a major experience
about six years ago, and
Netflix was splitting the DVD
and streaming business as a part.
And we made a big mistake.
And the customers went from loving
us to hating us pretty quickly,
and it took us many years to earn
back the trust, and out of that,
you know, we really learned a lot
about listening to the customers.
If we saw something that
was a long-term strategy,
it's just going a little bit slower
and bringing customers
along with us.
It's also what made me realize I
could never do electoral politics,
because, you know, I just
don't have the ear for it.
And so I'm really built for
business, and I encourage people
to really think about, you know,
what they're good at, and, you know,
from myself, I realize
I'm good at business,
so I'm happy paying my
taxes and volunteering some
and being very thankful for
the public servants amongst us.
>> Ann Compton: All of our
mothers probably tell us
when you make a mistake, apologize.
Is that a good business strategy?
>> Reed Hastings: Generally, yes.
[laughter] But I would
say to be frank,
I mean the customers
don't care that much.
They want the thing fixed.
You know, the apology is okay,
but if you think the
apology itself is going
to make a big difference,
there's deeper issues.
>> Elaine Chao: I'm Asian America.
I always apologize.
[laughter]
>> Ann Compton: Ladies
and gentlemen, oops,
let's take a few questions,
and I'm going to start
with a Peace Corp volunteer
in Tonga.
Adkins Trout [phonetic] has
a question for Reed Hastings.
Let us please go to the question
from Tonga, here is Adkins Trout.
>> Elaine Chao: Oh my
God, that looks great!
>> [Inaudible] Hi, my
name is Adkins Trout,
and I'm a Peace Corp
volunteer here in Tonga.
I work in the education sector,
and my question today
is for Reed Hastings.
In a world where the
gap between the rich
and the poor is rapidly
widening every day,
what do you think are some of the
ways that service work can be useful
in helping privileged people
in the developed world
better understand their peers
in the developing world?
Thanks.
>> Reed Hastings: Well,
in the world-wide basis,
actually inequality has sharply
declined over the last 30 years.
We've got many, many fewer
on a global basis and poverty
than we've ever had thanks to
the benefits of trade and of all
of the international work
that everyone is doing.
But to get to the question, which
is how do you create more empathy
and awareness, some of that is
definitely through entertainment.
Some of our shows, like
Three Percent coming
out of Brazil is an
amazing show about elites
and the meritocracy
and very insightful.
Another of our shows, Orange is the
New Black, is set here in the U.S.,
but it's a sector of the population
that very few people have
exposure to, women in prison.
So often entertainment is really
what opens people's hearts
and gets them to connect
in what we're doing.
>> Ann Compton: Wonderful.
We have a question
from the University
of Hawaii for Secretary Chao.
Victoria Cuba.
We have that question coming--
>> My name is Victoria Cuba.
I am a junior at the
University of Hawaii
at Manoa studying journalism
and digital media.
My question is for secretary Chao.
As the first Asian American
woman to be appointed
to the President's Cabinet and as a
former director of the Peace Corp,
what is the one inspirational
thing you would like to share
with other women of minority
looking to serve others?
>> Elaine Chao: Have confidence in
yourself, don't be afraid, explore.
I mean when I was growing up, I knew
so little about mainstream America,
but I had wonderful parents, a
wonderful family, and they imbued
within me a tremendous gift,
and as I mentioned earlier,
that was the gift of curiosity.
My parents, you know, sacrificed
so much to bring us to America,
and even though they could not
envision what futures lie ahead
of their six daughters, there were
six of us, they were confident
that this country will
offer them opportunities
that they cannot imagine
but that they knew existed.
>> Ann Compton: You were the eldest
of six daughters as I recall.
>> Elaine Chao: Yes.
>> Ann Compton: Does the eldest
have a special responsibility
or get special pressure?
>> Elaine Chao: Of course.
As Asian American families,
I'm the one in charge,
and I take care of everybody.
I don't know whether my sisters
will all agree that I'm the one
in charge, but I do
take care of everybody.
>> Ann Compton: We'll
do one more question
from the University of Hawaii.
This one is for Reed Hastings,
and the question comes
from a student, Tyler Gentile.
>> Aloha. My name is Tyler Gentile.
I'm a senior at the
University of Hawaii
at Manoa studying communications.
My question is for Mr. Hastings.
How does your experience abroad
in the Peace Corp attribute
to your success as an entrepreneur?
>> Reed Hastings: I think the
experience abroad has helped me
tremendously in terms of
empathy in connect with people
that you didn't grow up with,
and fundamentally in business
and communications, it's trying
to get out of your own skin
and to understand how a message
might be received as opposed
to just what you're saying.
And so you get a lot of practice
with that being a high school
math teacher in rural Swaziland.
>> Ann Compton: I would like to
open up the floor now to questions
from the audience here
in Washington as well.
I see a couple of hands going
up, two or three over here,
and we have a microphone
coming down the-- good evening.
Thank you for joining
us, and speak right up.
>> Yes, good evening.
I have a short question for
secretary Chao and for Mr. Hastings.
Secretary Chao, you mentioned
public private partnerships.
Would you be open to them
in passenger rail as well?
And to Mr. Hastings, do you see
there being I guess some the without
or three skills that you took from
being that math teacher in Swaziland
that you say you use every
day in your current work?
>> Elaine Chao: I'm so sorry,
I didn't hear the question.
Would I be open to what?
>> Public private partnerships
in passenger rail,
like long distance
passenger trains and the like.
>> Elaine Chao: I think that will
be very interesting to explore.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> Reed Hastings: And the
skills, I think, you know,
are really what you learn in
teaching is classroom management,
public speaking, some of those
skills are some of the most useful.
>> Ann Compton: Public speaking.
Get that students.
I don't see a microphone on this--
oh yes, please go find someone over
here, and we'll get a microphone
to the next question over here.
>> Hi, hello.
Thank you, Madam Secretary and
Mr. Hastings for coming to speak.
My question is about if you
think that there is a trend
in public service towards
or for the privileged,
and to give some context why I'm
asking this question is we see,
you know, on Capitol Hill,
many internships are,
they don't offer a stipend let
along like the metro stipend,
and even within the federal
government, if you try to apply
for an internship, many of those
offered do not offer any kind
of an assistance or
even a metro stipend.
And so my question is, you know,
Madam Secretary, you had mentioned
in the Peace Corp that there are
barriers because some people cannot,
you know, work for free
especially full-time hours,
and so what are your thoughts
on this, and how can we fix it
because obviously from
both of you speaking
that public service
is very important,
but there are economic
barriers, and it kind of sounds
like we've given some people, you
know, the vehicle and the key,
but there's no actual
gas in the car to,
you know, do public service, so--
>> Ann Compton: Practical question.
>> Elaine Chao: I'm not so negative.
I really think this country
has incredible opportunities,
and what I encourage in young
people and in parents is to believe
in the goodness of this country
and to find, be resourceful
and find different ways to
have different experiences.
I think there are very
few people, like myself,
who came to this country with
very, very little, but I was armed
with the most wealthy of assets,
and that is a sense of who I am,
and I was also fortified
by the love of my family.
Armed those two tremendous
treasures, that gave me the courage
to out and explore and
do all sorts of things.
So I was on scholarship
during my years in college.
Then as our family situation got
better, I gave the scholarship back,
and now my family establishes
scholarships for others.
So I think the most important
thing I would say is never give
up because there's
so many philanthropic
organizations in this country.
I was head of United Way.
I was director of the Peace Corp.
When I was head of United Way,
I never felt that I was
begging anyone for money.
It felt that I was giving them
an opportunity to participate
in the ground floor on
something bigger than themselves,
more important than themselves.
There's so many generous
benefactors who want to help,
and so there are many ways you know
to connect those in need with those
who want to give, and that's part of
the function of the social sector,
the volunteer sector, so I just
really encourage people, number one,
not be afraid, because when I
first came to America, if anything,
if I can something to
the young Elaine Chao,
it would be don't be afraid.
There are so many people
who want to be of help.
So [inaudible] yourselves, find
what you love to do, and go out
and help find others who
can help make that happen.
>> Ann Compton: Could
you add to that Reed?
>> Reed Hastings: I think
that was a great answer.
>> Ann Compton: If you
don't have the resources,
how do you go find them?
>> Reed Hastings: I don't have
anything to add to that one.
>> Ann Compton: Okay.
We have a microphone right here.
I'll get to you shortly.
Yes? Can you stand and thank you?
>> Hi. Thank you for
this informative panel.
My name is Contesa Verbon
[phonetic] from the New York Times.
I'd like to ask the panelists, how
do you make Peace Corp relevant
in view of [inaudible] has Peace
Corp withdrawn from other countries
that are involved in extremism.
>> Elaine Chao: I believe the
acting Peace Corp director is here.
I hope to see her.
I have not seen her yet.
The Peace Corp is in so
many different countries.
>> Ann Compton: Yeah, please stand.
>> Elaine Chao: You should get
up and answer this question.
>> Ann Compton: Please
stand, thank you [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Elaine Chao: Peace
Corp is involved
in so many different countries, and
I think in an international world
in which we are in,
Peace Corp volunteers
who understand other cultures,
who understand America,
can be great bridges
of understanding
in an increasingly
complicated international world.
>> Ann Compton: Find her afterward.
We have another microphone.
Yes, right here.
Please stand.
>> Hi, my name is Liz, and I was
inspired by my Peace Corp service
in Morocco to start something
called Corp Africa [phonetic],
which is Peace Corp for Africa.
And they are so proud to be,
they're inspired by Americans,
but they love their countries.
And I would be so honored to
pass along your advice to them
as they try to create a
service, a cultural service
in [inaudible] countries.
>> Elaine Chao: Thank you.
>> Reed Hastings: Are
you asking for advice?
I think what you are doing is great,
and it's emblematic of what one
of the impacts of the Peace Corp
is, which is changing the volunteers
so that when they come back to the
U.S. that they're a voice for all
of these kinds of efforts.
So it's great, thank you.
>> Ann Compton: We have
a microphone over here,
and then I promise I'll
get it down here to you.
Yes, thank you.
>> Hi, Secretary Chao, my
name is Jen-tu [phonetic].
I'm very proud of you
as an Asian American
to serve our country
for so many years.
Thank you for doing that.
I brought my daughter, 13
years old, to get inspired.
I myself came to the
country 22 years ago,
and I went to [inaudible] leadership
program in Montgomery county,
Maryland, and I found very few
immigrants, first-generation,
that's how I call myself, to be in
those leadership programs and offer
to do a certain level
of public service.
And I still find myself, right
now I dedicated myself to,
I run a small business but
try to encourage community
to participate more in the social
and political and political activity
in the United States to
be 100 percent American.
But I found myself very challenging
to change the mentality of people
like me to be fully participate in
the society because they always say,
hey, you know, maybe my language
or maybe my culture is not
fully adapted to the country.
So what is your suggestion to
the first-generation Americans
like myself, to be able to fully
participate in the American life.
Thank you.
>> Elaine Chao: You know, I
understand their plight very well
because when you're first
generation, I'm first generation,
you worry about survival.
You just want to have
financial security.
So for a lot of these first
generation their first priority is
to be able to be financially secure
and take care of their families.
I am confident that as their
financial situation gets better they
will become more and more integrated
and take a larger role
in mainstream America.
I think as their children
becomes better assimilated
that they would take a
larger and larger role.
So I complement you
for your efforts.
I want you to kind of continue
because I think it's important,
and I have faith and hope
that as people get more financially
secure they are turning out.
But then in the meantime I
ask them also to get involved
in their local communities.
So for my parents, my mother
didn't speak English, it was very,
they were very active in the
Chinese American community,
and I thought that
was important as well.
>> Ann Compton: Thank
you for that question.
We have one over.
Hi.
>> Hello. I have a
question for Secretary Chao.
You mentioned that when you
entered the Peace Corp you wanted
to bring the diversity
of American into the Corp
such as recruiting people from
different ethnicities perhaps,
perhaps some different
economic statuses as well.
What about the diversity of age.
Lillian Carter of course was
famous for going to India
when she was in her late 60s.
How common is that, and of course
there's life-long learning,
but there's also life-long teaching.
And many of our mature older
people do have the time
to volunteer for the Peace Corp.
>> Reed Hastings: It sounds
like we've got a new volunteer.
>> Elaine Chao: I think
that's a great observation,
and I think Peace Corp, again the
acting Peace Corp director is here,
Peace Corp has always had a certain
percentage of more mature citizens,
but I will point out that Peace
Corp volunteers work in very,
very difficult positions.
And so in some of these
localities that the health needs
of someone who's more mature becomes
more important, and the remote areas
of Peace Corp volunteers
are assigned,
and sometimes the lengthier access
to healthcare facilities could
be a factor in recruiting more
of more mature Americans.
>> Ann Compton: I don't know
what the current numbers are,
but I expect during your tenure--
>> Elaine Chao: Sorry.
It's hay fever, not the cold.
During your tenure, the number
of retirees or senior Americans
who had the time to devote for that
was a small percentage of this?
>> It was about 10 percent usually.
>> Reed Hastings: Can I ask
the acting Peace Corp director.
Please, yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> So my name is Sheila Crowley.
I'm the acting director of
the Peace Corp. And a couple
of points on the diversity.
I just want to point out that
we have a made amazing strides
in representing the face
of America, and 36 percent
of our applicants are
now ethnically,
represent as ethnically diverse, and
what we call our onward strength,
meaning the volunteers in the
field, is about 28 percent
up from 14 percent since 2010.
So were making really great strides,
and we have good strategies,
and it's working.
In terms of age diversity, which
we also recognize as a need,
it's only about seven percent of
50 plus, but we have a program
for both called Peace Corp response
where our short-term targeted
project based assignments
that are sort of tailored
to people with experience
and generally those are older folks.
So we are very open and welcoming
to people who are 50 plus.
>> Ann Compton: Let me ask
you two quick followups.
When you talk about a
short-term targeted program,
that might be very, very attractive
to somebody who is just about to,
you know, to retire from workforce
but doesn't want to sit home.
Are you talking about two or
three weeks, five or six months,
or does each project have
a different character?
>> So it depends on the project and
the country and the need, but three,
six, nine, twelve months, and then
actually I do just want to point
out that our, I think our oldest
serving volunteer just left Morocco.
She's 85 years old.
>> Elaine Chao: Wow.
>> Reed Hastings: Awesome.
>> She's pretty amazing, and
I was a country director,
and my oldest volunteer was 80.
And that also sent a powerful
message to our partners in the field
that we were never too
old or young to serve.
>> Ann Compton: And may I
ask you one other question
which had come in, which had come
in from a Hawaii student asking
how can you, what can you say
to minorities and nontraditional
volunteers to encourage them
to go ahead and explore the
possibility of a Peace Corp service?
>> So the first thing I would
say is talk to a recruiter,
and we have recruiters
around the United States,
but the other thing I
would say is I think
in the past Peace Corp would often
be sort of viewed as something
that you sort of did
after college to get away
and to have a great experience,
but you were really
putting your career on hold.
I think Peace Corp now
is a career accelerator.
It always has been, but we've
really sort of in the 21st Century
with the Internet and all
the different projects
that volunteers are doing, there's
incredible benefits in terms
of leadership development,
flexibility, adaptability,
all the things that were mentioned,
and then we have benefits.
We have a scholarship program
that return Peace Corp volunteers
can apply to for graduate school
after Peace Corp. It's
called the Fellows program.
And then we also have a
readjustment allowance
that helps them get started when
they reenter the United States.
So we have lots of benefits
that would serve them.
>> Ann Compton: Thank you very much.
>> Sure.
[ Applause ]
>> Ann Compton: I think we have time
for one more question
from the audience.
Yes, you've been very
patient waiting.
Thank you so much.
>> Thank you so much.
Glenn Bluehorse, president of
National Peace Corp Association,
and I served in the Peace Corp
in Guatemala in 1988 to '91.
Secretary Chao, thank you for
your decades of public service
and national service and Reed for
your service in the Peace Corp
and elsewhere, and you
are very inspiring,
and this is certainly an evening
of inspiration and for service.
As a matter of fact, thanks to
the great recruitment process
that Peace Corp has
now, over 20,000,
sometimes close 25,000
individuals are applying to serve
in the Peace Corp, but with
funding for only 7000 volunteers
at any given time, thousands of
individuals, American citizens,
young global citizens, young
citizens who would like to serve
in the Peace Corp don't
have that opportunity.
What can with do about that?
And the question is for
either or both of you.
How can we ensure that those
Americans have the opportunity
to serve?
>> Reed Hastings: Why I think what's
been amazing about the Peace Corp is
that it's very, I have
the numbers approximately
from 2500 to 5000 down to four.
I didn't know it was up to
seven now and that it's been
over 50 years quite
a stable program.
So you wouldn't want
to grow it too quickly.
I think you might see a whole
number of side effects of that,
and on balance, it's been
incredible bipartisan support
in good and bad budget times.
The funding's been really reliable
compared to many federal programs,
and so I think we should also just
be positive about what we've got
in the Peace Corp for the budget.
>> Elaine Chao: Can I just
go back to the question,
one of the previous
question was asked.
I think it's also important, again,
speaking from the Asian
American perspective, you know,
for us I think it's really
important that we help our parents,
and I say this to young people.
Their parents may not understand
what Peace Corp is all about.
So for these young people,
who at least in the Asian American
community, you have to kind
of convince your parents that
this is a good path forward.
And so I would encourage
young people to kind
of explain what Peace Corp is as
they make this decision, you know,
to those around them,
so that they understand
and will support that decision.
>> Ann Compton: As a moderator,
I'm going to take the opportunity
to not ask the last question.
We have one more videotaped question
from a Peace Corp volunteer,
who is in Guatemala, and let me
introduce now Susanna Gonzales.
>> Hello, my name is
Susanna Gonzales.
I'm a Peace Corp volunteer
in Guatemala working
on youth development.
My question is for both
secretary Chao and Mr. Hastings.
How do we make opportunities
to serve an organization
such as the Peace Corp more
assessible to those who come
from disadvantaged
communities in the states?
>> Ann Compton: Well,
we have touched on this,
but let me give both of you a
chance to sum up your thoughts.
I love the fact that she's
on a rooftop with the horns--
>> Elaine Chao: A dog--
>> Ann Compton: With
the dogs barking
and the true Peace Corp experience.
If you could sum up how you think
the skills that you have been able
to learn from not only
the leadership
but in business would
translate into bringing some
of those less traditional
volunteers into--
start with you, Secretary Chao.
>> Elaine Chao: I think Rick needs
to answer this because Rick is
so extraordinarily successful,
and people don't think
about the transition from Peace
Corp into the business sector,
so I think you would have a
lot of encouragement to offer.
>> Reed Hastings: Yeah, in
answering our volunteer's question,
the Peace Corp in the last 10 or 15
years has made a big effort in terms
of diversifying, and you
heard some of the numbers,
and so I really think we're
on the right course, you know,
as finding great role models, where,
you know, it's not just white men
and white women, you know, talking
about how great the Peace Corp was
because people, you know, follow
the role models that they see.
And so as we have more volunteers
like Susanna, I think it's natural
that it's spreading and so I
think it's a really big success.
>> Ann Compton: Last word?
>> Elaine Chao: I think
that the life skills
that Peace Corp volunteers learn
is very helpful and very applicable
to all aspects of life and also in
any chosen occupation or career.
The qualities of flexibility,
curiosity, and being resourceful.
I mean these Peace Corp volunteers
are thrown into pretty interesting
and unexpected circumstances
and situations,
and they have to learn how to
adjust and be problem solvers.
>> Reed Hastings: We're
going to get you back
as a second term Peace
Corp director.
You have such passion for it.
>> Elaine Chao: I'll go back
as a Peace Corp volunteer.
>> Reed Hastings: A volunteer next.
Okay.
>> Ann Compton: Thanks to the
internet world, we live in a world
where we all think we know much more
about the world than we used to,
but there's nothing like
boots on the ground and living
within another culture to not only
appreciate what they are going
through but what the United States
has in terms of values, standards,
business, practices, and
human-to-human contact
that really makes it exceptional.
Thank you so much, Secretary Elaine
Chao, Rick Hastings of Netflix,
and thank you all for joining us.
>> Elaine Chao: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Edward Widmer: Thank
you all so much.
What a wonderful panel.
We're deeply grateful to Secretary
Chao and Reed Hastings today.
They came a long way
to be here tonight,
and we're grateful
to Ann Compton also.
We're always grateful to Mrs. Inouye
and the Daniel K. Inouye Institute,
and we're so happy that we
had the students in Hawaii
on the two campuses and the
many Peace Corp volunteers
around the world.
We couldn't see all of you, but we
felt your service and your idealism,
and we're inspired by you.
The Kluge Center and the Inouye
Institute will be putting forth two
more programs in this series
over the next two years.
Please stay in touch with us
via email or social media,
consult our website, and once again
thank you so much for coming out.
Good night.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.